you know the whole FDIC quarter of a
million dollars okay so if now you're
going to come and protect the positors
and you're saying they should do that
fine no problem then then you have one
of two decisions you guys got to make
either one you have to increase the 250
and put no limit which is kind of what
you're doing right now or raise it to a
number but if you say 250 and you're
willing to do that no limit then it's
not really 250. it's just a wink wink
250 hey be very careful but don't worry
about it we're gonna back you up even if
it's more than two one part of
government will pay you the 250 the
other part of government will give you
the rest so what's the right thing to do
do you think that that number needs to
be what Tom what do you think that
number needs to be well I agree with
Mark Cuban and Mark Cuban just said
shouldn't we move this to 500 like a
half a million dollars insured
um I I think that's a rational approach
now I'm all in favor of protecting
depositors I am one not of SVP but um I
am a depositor and I'd love to see
myself protected but I'll tell you what
I don't like what this basically tells
the banks is that you can be foolish
and the government's going to bail out
your depositors and you only have to
worry about the investors I I just think
when you when you make these bailouts
it's it's a moral hazard but I think it
should be 500 to your core point I think
it should be a little higher than that
um you know it's I think probably a
million is probably more realistic for
today's day and age and what that will
do is if you have money in payroll you
can probably do sweeps you can invest it
in treasuries and then bring it back in
the day before payroll it is the digital
age you could do these things however
um a million would would alleviate for
small businesses the need to kind of go
back and forth with more sophisticated
banking well you know how they say like
to make six figures ain't what it used
to be right so to use that to use that
analogy when did the FDIC 250 000 limit
come into effect how long ago was that
do we know can we google that because if
it was 50 years ago it's not the same
number it was a hundred thousand what if
we adjusted the 250 across time well
exactly I mean it wasn't 100 000 for a
long time was it I'm just trying to look
for I'm sure Rob is on the ball here but
like just like for instance this this uh
this past year we've seen that social
security has increased by like eight
percent to deal with inflation and the
cost of living CPI and all that I'm
wondering if that same uh metaphor could
be used for
the FDIC and by the way Rob when you do
that can you also run a poll on the
podcast right now since we're on the
topic of what they think it needs to be
increased to should it stay at I'm
asking this question on Twitter well
keep it at keep it at 250 okay I'm more
towards you which is I think a million
bucks is enough because we can keep it
at a million for 10 years 20 years and
you just kind of keep it at that number
and also Pat you don't want it to be too
much more than that because then you got
to pay insurance on that where that
would put some banks that are smaller in
a tough position mm-hmm
and you bring up a good point there
Barry a lot of these bank accounts are
companies businesses I don't know too
many just Average Joe's just with
quarter Mill in the bank maybe a million
bucks in the bank
um but a lot of these are companies that
that don't want to diversify imagine if
you're a company with five million
dollars in assets you don't want to deal
with 10 different banks
like kind of what Cuban said you have
all these fees it'd be great for the
banks but you just want to consolidate
keep it simple uh that's a good point
right especially if it's payroll that
you're dealing with again you could
avoid that by putting it in treasuries
and back and forth but that puts strain
on a small company you know you got a
bookkeeper or one you know if you're a
company with 15 20 people it's it's it's
it's not easy also in treasuries isn't
there sort of a lock-up period you can't
just you can do like you can do it where
it can match
um your payroll periods you could you
could stagger it yeah but that's what it
gets very complicated yes yeah exactly
keep it simple still put the kiss
principle so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]